- This is The Belly Room, and
this is where it all started.
- It's a very special place,
it's sort of a comics-only vibe.
- I think I forgot
my jokes, fuck.
- So, will they, don't worry.
- Jessie's a...
- Fucking patience.
- Let me take a
shit on that paper,
so there's something
funny on it.
(laughing)
- When a joke bombs,
it's like falling
backwards through a window.
- You look like the
hottest waitress
in the North Dakota Denny's.
- But when a joke kills
up here in the Belly Room,
it's thunder.
Joe and my mom are both
disgusting alcoholics.
The only difference is one
funny came out of my mom.
I basically want to
commit hate crimes
that I get a trophy for.
What's a podcast called, WTF who
the fuck.
- There's a thing
called The Wave.
They're like a gorilla
sketch team, it's insane.
- [Voiceover] Yeah!
- This should be really good.
- That's the kind of
theatrics one does
when they don't write jokes.
- Oh!
- You only roast the
ones you love, and
I mean, I don't love him.
- Can you scoot
over bro, thank you.
- Because he's Mexican,
but I like him.
George is no stranger
to stereotypes,
because he's stolen
Sonys, Samsungs, JVCs,
pretty much any stereotype
you can get out of a Honda.
- It's the loveliest kind of
joke, because it's personal,
because a good roast joke
requires knowing you.
- You know what Guy,
you wish you had my hair
because guys, when
they ride you,
have to grab onto your neck fat.
(audience groaning)
- [Voiceover] It works for us.
- Some of these comics
have nothing to lose, and
everything to gain by
killing in the roast battle.
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] I
like it, I like it.
(applause)